and maybe you don't know who I am
but
I'm batman and these are my officers
[Music]
searching and searching not knowing what to wear
so at that moment he had me on
social networks on twitter he had me bad
boy well it's because of a photo of me
when I was a child dressed as a rabbit then
I had put him in profile and I had
put myself with the bad rabbit after
balboni and searching and searching like a
man with the map that is,
the first essential thing is glasses
I think that since I was a child I have always
loved having  glasses is a real
real passion like since I was a little boy, the paris
at family parties at school
always looked for trouble because you
can't have sunglasses and I always
wore glasses so I
love different or rare glasses it's hard to
find any career in colors  Really,
I don't have a specific glasses, it's like for
seasons I almost always rotate them,
I rotate the glasses even
when I've been wearing one for a long time and
I say and  Enough of using it and when I finish
a show I give it to a fan I almost
always do that and I always buy new ones
as I don't keep them with me
I'm always going to roll it around
nothing
ok tights tights I always have to
take colored tights with me
from somewhere  funny design either to
show it off or simply to have it more
feel good and to have it on even though he
says don't even go with yellow which
is my favorite color
pink is the same
as canoeing
[Music]
obviously if I arrive halfway to put on
tennis shoes or I can't travel  without my sneakers,
specifically, it's not even
bad because I couldn't find my 6 and
always the 15, so as I said, I
'm going to buy them, I don't care, I
want them, even if it's to wear them around my
neck,
these sneakers are never missing on my trips
I have them from the beginning of my
career from the first day, so the
dynamic is that it has changed with me to
all the places I go to all the
countries and on the platforms  the most
important ones that I have climbed because they
have also been there and it is like very symbolic
for me they are the ones that have always eaten they
do not travel with me but if they cannot be
absent from my house there always have to
be 2 - to play either with my
friends  Before, I used to play a lot with my
family, my dad with my grandfather, my uncle,
both culturally from Puerto Rico, Latinos
in general,
so about a special edition
I bought them played, I still don't know,
a special moment in Puerto Rico- stop,
you can go there on the beach  Along the
trail, where is the edition? Ask
where the dons are outside talking.
The guerrilla gets tough, daughter
[Music]
and enamel is almost always black so that it
is the most general, obviously black
because it goes with everything. I also like to
take that color with me.  vivo gave me a
different design even more I have
black to be able to keep it neutral next
my wrestling championships I like to
take them with me when I go to make
big presentations  special is that
I don't know I'm not very superstitious I've never
been but as for this as
it doesn't give me certain security and where
I am the champion then I wear it as if
they symbolize what we don't have and are
and that is always good  difficult
as many of us really like
what it was
[Music
] wicca always has to be with me
because well I'm not a person who
exercises a lot so at least
try to maintain some rhythm and I think that
to apply it in the funniest
way it can be easy  to be in the room where the
show is, I think it's the most
convenient when it comes
to health issues, salomé,
very bad magazines, composed by the top
bastard,
I don't trust, they don't trust wine anymore,
wine can never be missing in
my house, I always like it, we have
little bottle of wine and us in
special moments or if there is not a
special moment it becomes very special
besides that a glass of wine is
healthy a day for the heart is a
bottle of wine with your m  irada that they
gave me in Chile they made a
special label with a doll simulating that
the year was already very cool I have nine
bottles at home in which a
million doll comes out in the park but with
my friend it is no longer
clear the one that did not have the photo  the only one
I kept putting but it doesn't matter the
same I think yes
only
the doctor told me that this is not all
that comes here it looks good tiny
it looks insignificant but in my
whole life inside a package I can't see without
my glasses so there is a
problem I love wearing dark glasses
so things don't go together because
I always wear my contact lenses
the really most essential thing is
wallets I always have to have an
accessible little bag it's specifically
from the very
very small intern that I found and bought it and
inside that's where we're windy
direction and this was essential perhaps when I
was five or six seven years old it was very
essential I don't expect it anymore but it's always
good to remember it
was your favorite  wow in my favorite
game in game boy I think it was the gold
edition of pokemon
[Laughs]
and my last essential item is I
don't drink
ok if it loads me even if it's incomplete to
talk but it can be connected to
any television
[Music]
this is probably the one  the
phone cord I think is more important
than the phone itself because the phone
without the charger so I think it's in
the first place partly with my
contact lenses the most essential thing my doctor
also told me about the phone
[  Music]
thanks getting back in the studio and hanging
out with me this was
racially essential to him
[Music]